lassen sie uns heute mal direkt über ein
wirklich ekliges tabu thema sprechen
arbeit dienstag war tag der arbeit
müsste man dringend umbenennen in tag
der arbeit von der viele nicht mehr
leben können die ist oft nur noch
befristet gibt zu der hunderttausende
aufstocken was echt ein skandal ist aber
kaum ein juckt weil uns viel mehr
interessiert dass heidi klum jetzt in
dem kleinen typen von tokio herum kurz
tag der arbeit ja weiß nicht wie es
irgendwo aber es sind doch nur noch
leere rituale und sinnlose live-schalten
zu mai demos die sicherheitsvorkehrungen
sind auch groß die bvg hat heute also
viele berlinerinnen und berliner sind
sie unterwegs aber auch touristen also
das maifest sieht auf jeden fall ich
habe den verdacht hier wird alkohol
ausgeschenkt also moment nein wirklich
gut kombiniert schulung
du bist zu einer großen sache auf der
spur ja es ist natürlich so den tag der
arbeit muss man sich inzwischen schön
saufen
neueste zahlen über 3,7 millionen
beschäftigte in vollzeit verdienen bei
uns unter 2000 euro brutto übrigens
morgen wird karl marx 200 glückwunsch
von hier an der stelle
er feiert aber nicht weil er tot ist
aber wie recht der mann hatte stichwort
entfesselter kapitalismus 2,2 millionen
deutsche werden mit tricks um den
mindestlohn beschissen kriegen weniger
als mindestlohn warum ich will nix böses
ich will nur begreiflich machen es gibt
menschen deren produktivität ist eben
nicht 50 sondern darunter auch das
gehört zur wahrheit in der woche des
tags der arbeit es sind nicht alle
menschen 850 wert also vom material wird
schon die die organe klappt aber
ansonsten eben immer ein beispiel
gebäudereiniger gebäudereiniger dem
kannst du vielleicht auf dem papier
mindestlohn geben auch nicht in
wirklichkeit also zahlt man nicht pro
stunde sondern pro zimmer
eine reinigungskraft muss beispielsweise
eine bürofläche von 420 quadratmeter
saubermachen hat dafür aber nur eine
stunde zeit nicht zu schaffen
nicht mal ein halbes wohnzimmer arbeitet
arbeitet die freiheit mal länger es
heißt ja stundenlohn nicht stundenlohn
einfach mal drüber nachdenken bevor man
die kommende vollbeschäftigung ab feiert
wir unsere frau merkel sollte man
vielleicht mal die ausbeutung im land
stoppen
zum beispiel auch in der logistikbranche
da muss der staat doch mal eingreifen
oder ich weiß nicht wen ich ist die spd
ich glaube das ist einfach nicht
akzeptabel ist dass leute hier wirklich
teilweise monatelang in ihren lkws leben
und da muss was passieren
was muss passieren das ist eine gute
frage
sie sahen das offizielle ende der
arbeiterpartei spd bitter
sag mal was machen wir denn da
ja
wenn er kandidiert vorschlag von mir
internationale konzerne müssen in
zukunft vielleicht mal mit deutschen
gewerkschaften zumindest reden
die tarifbindung im land nimmt nämlich
rapide ab gebe immer noch ein beispiel
der lieferdienste delivery
da müssen die auslieferer selber ihr
fahrrad bezahlen und nachdem sich die
kölner fahrer im dezember in einem
betriebsrat organisiert haben wurden die
verträge dieser angestellten nicht
verlängert da fangen jetzt fast nur noch
freelancer für noch weniger geld
also gibt es bald keine angestellten
fahrer mehr für die gewerkschaft ein
dilemma da ist natürlich schwierig einen
betriebsrat auch handlungsfähig zu
behalten wenn es eben keine belegschaft
mehr gibt die lieber ruhe in frieden
betriebsrat
allerdings hat einen job bei denen auch
echte vorteile hier so werben die
ernsthaft um neue fahrrad sklaven da ist
es fit bleiben und damit geld verdienen
besser geht es für mich mich würde mir
wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut tun
jetzt liegt werden wie ein libero kurier
wer das was du fettes schwein sich den
ganzen tag für uns abstempeln
da purzeln die pfunde andere idioten
gegenden teure fitnessstudios eigentlich
müsstest du uns bezahlen du verbrennt
kalorien beim radeln beim treppensteigen
und bei ausgang und den wutanfällen wenn
du deine de leve lohnabrechnung liest
und wenn es für die miete nicht mehr
reicht schlaf doch einfach in der
ausliefern box die libero arm aber sexy
back
yahoo
ja
einzelfall
kein einzelfall aber ein super beispiel
für den so genannten plattformen
kapitalismus unternehmen wie otto oder
die liu vermitteln dienstleistungen über
das internet
ich sage eigentlich müsste es noch viel
mehr solche personal und lohn sparen des
start-ups geben hier idee
rettungssanitäter neben auf den weg zum
einsatz in der organe kühlbox noch sushi
mit sanitäter randow oder hier nochmals
film der randow ich meine man kann noch
nebenbei eine pizza ausliefern wenn man
sowieso gerade zum knattern in der
beethovenstraße ist und wenn sie in eine
dachbox auf ihrem auto haben
dann arbeiten sie als freiberuflicher
bestatter bei leiche randow hier warum
er nicht ausbeutung boomt in deutschland
deswegen ist es auch nur konsequent dass
man dem amazon chef jeff bezos in berlin
gerade ernsthaft den axel springer preis
verliehen hat ist ein vorzeige
unternehmer ausgezeichnet für
herausragende leistungen auf dem gebiet
der steuervermeidung was man dem herrn b
saß allerdings lassen muss er behält
seine angestellten stets liebevoll im
auge da kriegt jeder amazon arbeiter
sonst keiner
im grunde müssen sich das vorstellen wie
so ein babyfon für erwachsene
die gesammelten daten über ihn können
von den vorgesetzten direkt am laptop
eingesehen werden
er wird offenbar permanent überwacht ja
ich selber habe seit jahren das gefühl
dass ich meine arbeit gefilmt werden
aber ich kann es dem zdf nicht
nachweisen
hier ein original ausschnitt aus einem
amazon scanner protokoll gibt es beim
besonders faulen aber so ein mitarbeiter
eine inaktivität zwischen 8 15 und 8 und
und das auch noch kurz nach einem
toilettengang so ein verbessern ohne
druck auf die belegschaft läuft gar
nichts
das war schon beim pyramidenbau so ich
finde amazon macht das alles sehr
konsequent zum beispiel im
versandzentrum in leipzig martin
klempnow ist area manager in einem
großen amazon versandzentrum kanzlerin
wir wollen der vollbeschäftigung also
dass unsere mitarbeiter ständig weil
beschäftigte bei den sogenannten amazon
kickern überwacht der scanner die
performance ständiges feedback ist hier
der schlüssel hier knossalla der folge
ist 6 prozent langsamer als auch 20
minuten alle artikel waren irgendwie
problem oder verschärften abgelenkt es
wäre tatsächlich ein bisschen abwenden
sie sogar gebaute arbeiten hier
der hat zwar vier sekunden aber das war
doch gerade eben als etwas gefragt aber
ich glaube da fehlt ein bisserl beck
soll ich habe jetzt ein blutbad geben
wie attraktiv der kraftakt
ja wir haben hier ein chor tritt browser
einer schon seit zwei minuten inaktives
kann doch nicht wahr sein
klingt nicht wussten das auch alles tot
der mitarbeiter schon das klopapier
gestrichen aber glauben sie die herren
auch mit der kanone sprach ein roter
balken um das problem mit den toiletten
zeiten in den griff zu bekommen gibt es
in der amazon kann diene nur noch
bananen und zwieback war ein dass wegen
korken aufs klo gehen könnte dann ende
sommerferien die firma amazon sieht sich
als legitimer nachfolger der ddr und hat
deshalb überall kameras installiert
manfred in halle 3 hat einer gesagt geh
mal peter hin und schreiben abmahnung
der typ der betriebsrat gründen werde
mit der errichtung sri lanka betriebsrat
braucht amazon mitarbeiter sind abends
oft völlig am ende nur ihr scanner macht
nie pause
amazon würde ich doch aus wenn du tot
bist
[Applaus]